all right everybody we're back with the
one and only my dear friend Deborah
Norville now this story I loved um
because I struggle with timing myself
you know I like to have these really
in-depth conversations with people and I
heard a tip that when you are ready to
wrap it up that you have something you
do what is it okay so when I was on The
Today Show because it's very very finely
time oh and that is live and that is a
whole different thing they will cut you
off the computer will cut you off
Vaudeville hook so I said to this person
I was interviewing I said because they
were not a professional there was
somebody who was just an amateur who
doesn't go on TV a lot right when it's
time for us to wrap up I'll just I'll
just briefly you know I'll just tap you
with my foot but that means comfortably
finish what you're saying so I get the
the sign from the person behind the
camera I go like that nothing happens I
hit a little bit harder I'm not gonna
hit you as hard as I hit this person I'm
basically beating the pie out of this
guy
finally I have to cut him off he had a
prosthesis
[Applause]
the other leg
I was so embarrassed and then I felt I
felt like God I'm hurting I'm like he
doesn't have a leg it was the most
embarrassing thing that nobody knew I
was embarrassed right so I shouldn't
even be telling this story but I do what
how was your like goodbye to him like
did you imagine so much no God no no no
no okay no I'm like I mean if he's not
gonna bring it up I'm not going to bring
it up right I mean
yeah oh I should have mentioned or
something like that I'm like I'm not
going to say yeah you should have I'm
like you know have you guys been through
enough oh my God that is just it no then
there was another time I was
interviewing we were interviewing the
wives of the guys who were running for
president I won't tell you what was and
the interview's over and we stand up and
the commercial break and something fell
out of her skirt and you know how when
somebody drops something you make a move
to like go down and get it yes I'm
halfway down it's her retainer
she was so sweet though she was like oh
I'm so sorry and she she was even
quicker than me thank the Lord and she
picked that thing up oh my God I love it
and not just life when you're a
constantly yeah things happen okay now
speaking of things happen at work you
have done all this undercover stuff or
you know all this reporting as we start
at the beginning you know of all the
different lives jobs shoes rolls you've
stepped into so much us in one of them
was a jail cell that was not my choice
they made me go there they maybe go
twice so what is it they say fool me
twice shame on me so yeah but that this
this is what misery looks like I am
going around to these ladies and saying
I'm here because my producers don't like
me what are you in for because I wanted
to like know okay you just stole money
from the McDonald's I'm not too scared
of you you set your boyfriend on fire
and his leg burned off so I mean
seriously that was a lady in the cell
next too that's what I was interested in
yeah your roommate is someone like
terrified Bert their boyfriend like you
know yeah allegedly set him on fire do
you tiptoe around that person real
delicately
yeah we're like here have my dessert
yeah exactly oh my God I love that story
so much and here's the crazy thing so
she allegedly set her boyfriend on fire
the poor woman could not make bail she
was in jail for a year and a half
waiting trial finally came time to have
the trial her boyfriend missed and loved
her he refused to testify the woman got
out and they lived back together again
love is a beautiful thing
this is what we do at inside edition we
tell weird Happy Endings it's my
favorite because it's just so
dynamically diverse in its content and
that's something I want to do here I
love comedy why do we have to wait till
late night to laugh yes for that I want
to laugh in the daytime right right I
want to cover news I want to cover human
interest it would be wonderful to speak
to people of note I want to meet people
I've never met before I like to get into
fashion stuff we're going to do that on
this show I want to have takeaways I
want to learn how to live better I want
it to be all these things Inside Edition
is that and by the way the Pioneer in
digital the YouTube numbers are one
everyone admires every business on the
planet looks good Inside Edition of how
to do it I'm talking hundreds of
millions of hits and we have I think
it's 19 billion lifetime views it's
insane yeah there are it's so crazy so
you guys know we're a TV show you're
here at the taping of the TV show there
are young people like 10 12 14 years old
how they consume inside edition's a
digital show and they'll go to their did
you know there's this really great show
I see on the computer it's actually on
TV they think it's a new show on TV it's
crazy we'll take it well speaking of a
younger generation as a last story I
wanted to ask you about your daughter
because I as the mother of two dogs and
by the way this is also in honor of
Deborah it's my latest gratitude Journal
she's the one who
when we were launching the very
beginning show and I write in it you
know all the time and my daughter's
writing it you guys all write in the
same book oh yeah absolutely
um that was their latest entry it's a
hot mess but wait a minute I am grateful
for Mom
the and then you guys went on a trip oh
my god did you say that yet I didn't and
then Frankie says she's uh grateful for
sushi but it's spelled s-o-o-s
she might go to that school my daughter
went to they were all about phonetics
yeah yeah
good luck with that and then I I get
friends to write it so sometimes I'll
bring it to dinner and just be like
everybody writing it so you've changed
my life with this so and I'm raising my
daughters now to be aware of the
Gratitude Journal it's everywhere your
daughter made your producers or you
aware of a musician and she was like
what was she like Mom we got you got to
interview that she did she said mom
there's this new guy and he's really
good Entertainer singer and you need to
put them on Inside Edition so I went to
my producer and I said my daughter says
there's this amazing person we need to
put on Inside Edition and he ignored me
and Justin Bieber turned out to be
famous
okay so then cut to she suggests another
another group that she's already gotten
her dad to bring the CD from London so
she can have it Mom they're coming to
America for the very first time and
attention must be paid so I go to my
boss and say do not make me say I Told
You So twice and he said okay fine we'll
do the story on one condition that
Michaela does the interview my daughter
did the first American interview with
One Direction
and look at the kisses she got kisses
from every single whatever I mean
catcher every weekday on Inside Edition
and next if you're worried
enter we have a trick that's good so I
love my plants that was great thank you
so much
[Music]